I've always wanted one of these thought
I heard first talking someone downstairs
Diana it's a Justice League thing I
talked her into bringing me along I
thought we could get into some trouble
but I guess I missed all the fun yeah
it's not funny this is the Joker
even Diana thinks that he's scary Bruce
didn't want me there I went anyway
I'm thinking he was right what happened
what people died couldn't save them
I just feel like quitting I don't blame
you you think he's gonna quit - who the
Joker no verse says the Joker kills
people just because he can he's never
gonna stop
damnit why the hell do you always have
to be right because I'm older smarter
and prettier than you you and Bruce will
stop him I know you will because it's
what you do
Thanks you know versus good at a lot of
things not so much the pep talk things
get dark and you need someone to talk to
you I'm always here after all
a psychics gotta stick together
hey everybody it's Charlie we got a
whole bunch of new Wonder Woman Donna
Troy Justice League stuff to break down
from Titans if you're finding me for the
first time there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway - all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the episode on the video a
couple really big things happening in
this episode them introducing Donna Troy
obviously a really big deal because
she's going to be a big force on the TV
show in the future but also introducing
the Justice League or at least
confirming that they exist I think we
all kind of assumed that they did based
on the ages of the people and the way
they've established the universe
probably the biggest reason why you
don't see Justice League in the
arrowverse is because a lot of the
founding members are just becoming those
characters for the first time and the
Justice League doesn't form till after
those characters were already
established for a while so you have to
imagine in the arrowverse the older
versions of these characters will
eventually form the Justice League
although we can talk about that in my
arrowverse videos because they've
changed so much stuff about the comics
that everything's kind of wonky the
Titans universe does a little better job
of sticking to the original comics in
establishing things upfront like oh you
learn about Batman in the first episode
this is episode 8 we're learning about
the Justice League the universe just has
a much richer backstory starting out
than the arrowverse did like you were
just seeing all that stuff happened for
the very first time
Robin talks about the Joker killing a
whole bunch of people him and Batman not
being able to stop him and being really
bummed out about it that's probably one
of their early adventures together
because you have to imagine that he was
Robin up until about a year ago I think
this version of Robin is supposed to be
in his early to mid 20s so he's been
Robin for about ten years before he
quits and goes on his own and you see
the events of the TV show so when
they're talking about the Justice League
during this episode it might actually be
the original roster at least I'm hoping
I'm hoping Martian Manhunter exists in
this universe because that's the thing
that gets left out from a lot of modern
Justice League stories they brought him
back during rebirth because the original
version of the Justice League was Wonder
Woman Superman the flash Aquaman Green
Lantern Batman and Martian Manhunter we
already know that cyborg is going to be
a character on the Doom Patrol he might
already be a member of the Justice
League in present day so it wouldn't be
surprised if they do more Easter eggs if
they just tell us that the Justice
League has already been through a couple
different roster changes if they want to
stay accurate to the comics which it
seems like they do like all the stuff
that they reference
the way the characters look the stories
that they tell are all supposed to be
based on the original stories so we'll
see next year when cyborg shows up
because he's not gonna debut officially
until Doom Patrol episode 1 he's the one
that shows up and gives Doom Patrol
their mission to take down mr. nobody
who's the big villain of Doom Patrol
season 1 but we can talk about that when
we get a trailer the other big part of
this episode in addition to sort of
setting up the history of these
characters together like oh I used to be
Wonder Girl then I left that identity
behind to become Donna Troy was sort of
her being the big sister to Robin
giving him the inspiration to seek a new
identity like in the episode they make a
big joke of it like oh I thought that
you left Batman a long time ago no no no
I also left the Robin identity I even
burn my costume and she laughs at him
that's kind of dramatic those are
expensive minds in the closet and she's
probably talking about the red Donna
Troy costume we can talk about her
costume in a second because if she
continues to be a big thing on the show
I think that they will put her in a
version of one of her costumes but
they've all kind of tried to update the
Teen Titans costumes for modern purposes
so like Robins costume looks more like
armor I'm guessing the Donna Troy's red
costume also looks a little bit more
like armor the second conversation that
they had was a little more on the nose
about him becoming Nightwing I won't be
Batman
don't be Batman or Robin be something
else someone else who the funny thing
about that clip obviously they're making
a joke about him becoming Nightwing but
he says I'm not gonna be Batman he
actually does become Batman for a brief
period during the comics like he wears
the cape and cowl for a little while
people have been hoping to see Damian
Wayne on the show at some point I don't
know if he exists in the Titans universe
yet but when Graham Morrison introduced
into the comics for the first time he
was Robin to Nightwing's Batman because
Bruce Wayne wasn't around I mean
eventually he became Robin to Bruce
Wayne's Batman when he came back but it
does make you laugh about how hardcore
he is about not being Batman when he's
totally gonna become Batman at some
point just more evidence and
foreshadowing that they're definitely
going to turn him into Nightwing by the
end of the season but the actress that
plays Donna Troy has been doing a lot of
interviews because it's her big episode
this week and people have asked her if
she's gonna be a bigger member of the
team in the future
she talked around it a little bit but I
believe a while ago they did mention
that she would be a bigger thing in
season two but they haven't confirmed
how many episodes she'd be in or what
their other season two characters would
be because they did imply that Superboy
Conner Kent would eventually join the
show at some point they also implied
that Roy Harper might join the show in a
future season it would be a recast
version of the character it would not be
Colton Haynes right now he's playing old
man Roy on arrow and no idea where he's
gonna go in future seasons that they'll
keep bringing him back as for future
Justice League characters the only big
one that they haven't introduced yet is
Superman and I think they're probably
saving him for a Conner Kent Superboy
episode in the future typically they
introduced the big Justice League
characters when they introduced their
Teen Titans counterparts so like we just
learned about Wonder Woman for the first
time in the episode where they first
introduced on a Troy so I just expect
them to do the same thing for other
Justice League members so if you're
hoping for guards there Aqualad or some
Aquaman based character then they might
save Aquaman introduction for one of
those episodes because just based on how
the Aquaman movie is doing right now
I think they'll they'll definitely do a
sequel but probably not for another
three years so hopefully they'll be free
to do Automan characters if they want on
Titans without any big problems usually
that's the thing like if there's not a
big movie happening right away then
they're free to do whatever characters
they
that's how flash and arrow are able to
use Superman Tyler hoechlin for all
three episodes of the big crossover this
year just because there's not a really
big Henry Cavill Superman project
happening in the next couple of years
but everybody let me know in the
comments what do you think about Donna
Troy so far and what do you want them to
do with her in the future what's gonna
happen next week is we have the flash
100th episode and a whole bunch of
really big MCU Marvel stuff so it's
gonna be pretty crazy for the next
couple of weeks all the way through
Christmas leave all your DC video
requests in the comments below click
here to learn about why Netflix and
Marvel canceled daredevil and click here
for that brand new flash 100th episode
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight